разом із міністром освіти та науки
України Сергієм шкарликом пане Сергію
Вітаю вас
вітаю вас Доброго дня Слава Україні
Героям слава
навчального року позаду яким він був для
шкіл скільки шкіл змогли відкритися
офлайн станом на зараз у порівнянні з
першим вересня
Дуже дякую Яна вам за традиційну
цікавість до освіти адже це знову кажу
це про майбутнє перший місяць пройшов і
традиційно всіх освітян наприкінці на
початку жовтня Вітаю з днем працівника
освіти який відбувся вчора маємо
стриманий оптимізм стосовно взагалі
діяльності закладів освіти діяльності
наших освітян адже станом на сьогодні ми
маємо 2 мільйони 126 з половиною тисяч
дітей які сьогодні навчаються в
змішаному або в очному форматі і це бо
дуже
позитивна тенденція те що за перший
місяць кількість таких дітей збільшилась
майже на 10 з половиною тисяч які
сьогодні мають можливість
соціалізуватись в повному був змішаному
форматі навчання спілкуватись своїми
однолітками а це означає що 7714 шкіл
майже дві третини нашої шкіл працює саме
в очному змішаному форматі
якщо не мають укриття які розраховані на
всіх учасників освітнього процесу тобто
і учнів і викладачів Ми сьогодні дійсно
маємо також 5198 шкіл там де
відбувається дистанційний формат
навчання і 1 вересня ми але але це теж
досить позитивні тенденції адже майже на
400 закладів майже на 400 закладів
зменшилась кількість тих що працюють
саме в дистанційному форматі вже на
сьогодні
ми вже ці 400 закладів зробили ремонтні
роботи у сховищах так завдяки цьому вони
змогли відновити навчання офлайн
не тільки є 10 декілька факторів
стосовно перше за все це звичайно робота
тих комісій які відбувалися і так як ми
і розраховували десь на 15-20 вересня
кількість закладів освіти які мали мали
достойні укриття і комісії яких визнала
такий що можуть працювати в офлайн або
змішаному навчанні вони якраз і
збільшились окрім того є успіхи які Ми
радіємо наших збройних сил по частково
школи і і території нашої звільнюються
від від
певним чином з
[музика]
відштовхується лінія фронту вже на до
ближче до нашого кордону ми відвойовуємо
територію це так само дозволяє наші
школи підключатися вже і переходити в
більш звичний або змішаний формат
навчання
до речі про територію звільнення від
окупантів як відновлюються навчальний
процес на деокупованій Харківщині і чи
готові вчителі уже ставати до роботи Маю
на увазі тих вчителів які точно не
співпрацювали із окупаційною владою
щодо тих вчителів Хто не працює знав я
перше за все Ну так десь днів два або
три бачив сюжет про колаборантів взагалі
по Україні таких Мені здається було
виявлено по і пред'явлено звинувачення
десь 200 або 32 в 262 особи з них 4 було
з закладів освіти в цьому контексті хочу
сказати що зокрема нашім освітяни
Харківщини взагалі-то не припиняли
освітній процес він відбувався навіть
під обстрілами навіть в обосховищі І це
ще раз я пишаюсь своїм своїми колегами
освітянами оскільки і в тому числі і на
деокупованих терито
територіях які були під тимчасовою
окупацією наша вчителі співпрацювали з
своїми учнями впроваджували освітній
процес за українськими освітніми
стандартами і не залишали своїх
вихованців поза межами освітнього
процесу в усіх областях нас розроблений
чітке алгоритм стосовно того відновлення
Роботи під час деокупації вже після
офіційних процедур національної поліції
служби безпеки збройних сил України
проти мінної діяльності тому тому звісно
ми повністю налаштовані на те що
освітній процес має відбуватися попри
все
і формати для цього
продовжуючи тему вчителів Чи ви вбачаєте
тенденцію повернення українських
вчителів з-за кордону зараз в Україну
аби тут продовжити роботу
Дуже гарне запитання знов таки ця
проблема бо це запитання Воно лежить в
контексті перш за все довіри вчителя до
влади до системи організації освітнього
процесу довіри і успіхам наших збройних
сил України якщо ми нині за кордоном в
нас
перебуває
12900 вчителів які ми облікували то на 1
вересня в таких було 16 з половиною
тисяч А на
березень місяць 2022 року такі вчителі
було 27 тисяч тобто в нас тільки за
останній місяць повернулась
3424 вчителів ми пишаємось нашими
вчителями ми пишаємось нашими освітянами
І звісно я абсолютно впевнений що
настане той час коли всі українські
вчителі повернуться додому для того щоб
співпрацювати з своїми в тому числі
повного формату своїми вихованцями
надавати професі освітні послуги вчити
дітей здобувати і формувати не тільки їх
як як освітян А ще як свідоме громадян
України Ну і за кордоном у нас виникла
проблема те що студентам які вступили в
закордонні вище зараз ну закрили
можливість виїзду зокрема через те що
багато хто підробляв такі документи і
ефективно вступав у закордонні вищі Утім
ті хто дійсно наприклад отримали
можливість навчатися в сорбонії в
Гарварді щоб ви цим студентам чоловікам
порадили зараз робити
ви знаєте тут є декілька аспектів такого
питання перш за все мон ніяким чином не
здійснює пропуск через державний кордон
і не приймає рішення щодо пропуску
студентів або інших громадян через
державний кордон на жаль в Україні
відбувається повномасштабна війна звісно
з її особи чоловічої статі з 18 до 60
років виїзд їм заборонено звісно
студенти попадає під ту категорію яка не
підлягає мобілізації але при цьому але
при цьому це є мобілізаційний ресурс на
на випадок наприклад повної мобі
при цьому на сьогодні ті хто вступили ті
хто навчається по міжнародних договорах
ті за кого наприклад держава Україна
заплатила ті чи інші кошти наприклад по
обміну з однією стан з країн світу до
нас ідуть студенти по міжнародному
договору до когось від'їдуть інших кожне
питання треба розглядати окремо
Міністерство освіти і науки в нас іде
багато звернень від громадян від самого
студентів є від юридичних осіб ми ну в
принципі об'єктивно на сьогодні
намагаємося розглядати їх хоча б їх на
вал такий досить великий і в цьому
контексті і в цьому контексті кожне
звернення буде розглянуто при тому що ми
можемо поліцейський надавати певні листи
до Державної прикордонної служби
стосовно того що це для прийняття рішень
Державної прикордонної служби оскільки
Міністерство там наприклад чітко знає що
це міжнародний договір чітко знає що цей
студент вступив до там умовно
на навчання за довго до початку війни
Окрім цього що зробило Міністерство я
підписав листи від Міністерства Освіти і
Науки до своїх колег міністрів інших
країн світу стосовно того щоб нашим
студентам Які наприклад в цьому році
вступили на перший курс дали можливість
академічної відпустки наприклад на один
рік збереженням всіх фінансових
зобов'язань такого студента
для того щоб не пропали ці кошти для
можливості переведення їх в заклади
іншої освіти тієї чи іншої держави Щоб
забезпечити їм навчання онлайн якщо в
тому університеті де вступила ця людина
таку навчання немає Тобто Ну у
об'єктивно кожна ситуація є окремою і
унікальною А чи є взагалі
інформацією всту
пили з нас такої інформації немає але
звернень на сьогодні Ну більше трьохсот
Ну і про опалювальний сезон хочу з вами
поговорити який попереджає нас Влада Що
буде надскладним як це вплине на роботу
закладів освіти шкіл і університетів
на сьогодні завжди уряд України в і за
дорученням прем'єр-міністра
адміністратором ми завжди готувались до
опалювального сезону кожного року
заздалегідь на сьогодні за результатами
обстеження вже більше ніж 10,5 тисяч
шкіл готові до опалювального сезону А це
майже 88% від загальної кількості
закладів загальної середньої освіти в
нас є регіони зі 100% ви готовністю
закладів загальної середньої освіти до
опалювального сезону наприклад Вінницька
Волинська Житомирська івано-франківська
Кіровоградська Рівненська область на 99%
готові Одеси та місто Київ
Сподіваємось що
таких надфорс-мажорних обставин в нас не
буде і
освітяни будуть
А чи розглядається варіант переведення у
випадку перебоїв з теплопостачанням
школярів студентів на
змішану форму освіти або взагалі на
дистанційну
ви знаєте будь-які запасний варіант
завжди розглядається такі рекомендації
завжди давалися кожного року незалежно
від того навіть не під час війни
освітяни або засновники тобто місцеві
органи можуть змінювати графік
організації освітнього процесу від тих
чи інших обставин навіть і в тому числі
по економії паливно-енергетичних
ресурсів тому об'єктивно є є можливість
запасного варіанту Угу Ну бо я пам'ятаю
В моїй шкільній угоди був карантин так
званий через холодну зиму тому а тоді
війни не було ймовірно що цьогоріч знову
з цим доведеться зіштовхнутися Ну і
наостанок розкажіть нам коротко про
результати вступної кампанії до вишів де
був найбільший конкурс
ви знаєте традиційно 20 ми десь
приблизно після 12-го або після на
наступному тижні будемо давати певні
інформативні матеріали і
прес-конференції буде відбуватись щодо
підбиття підсумків
вступної кампанії то я думаю що давайте
ми цю інтригу залишимо до наступного
тижня я вийду з того на ефір до вас з
точними цифрами стосовно вступу з
розгорнутого вийдемо з інформацією про
вступ адже він він цього року особливий
е і його тільки так певними мазками
показувати не варто зрозуміло то
чекатимемо тоді наступної зустрічі
розкажете нам як все це відбувалося
Сергій шкарлет міністр освіти та науки
України долучився до ефіру